Hello everyone. How are you guys doing?
Hope you guys are having a wonderful
day. And today we're here with another
video. I know been a while. Been like
three or four days. Basically moved into
college and uh yeah, that was that was
quite an ordeal, but we got the internet
up and running. We're good now. So
basically what I'm here today is to show
you guys a fletching method that I've
recently actually posted in a video. I
said that it was a really good method.
It was profitable. It was quick. I was
like, "This is great." And it had to do
with amethyst bolt tips. Now, a lot of
people in that video were like just
roasting me because, you know, I mean,
typically if I release a video or if any
big YouTuber releases a video on a
money-making method, it gets ruined
right away. And a lot of people have
this like notion that as soon as it's
released, it's dead. No, stuff comes
back within a week all the time. I say
this all the time. I'm like, "Wait a
week, you're fine." People don't believe
me, but here we are today. 101,000
amethyst bolt tips, 102,000 broadbolts.
But if we go back and look at what I
bought these for, basically right here,
as you guys can see, my amethyst bolt
tips, I actually it probably average out
to around 270 each. Now, a lot were back
here. These do take a while to buy. Keep
in mind, you can only buy 11 or 12,000
per hour and 7,000 of these. So, uh,
that time that I was gone, I was buying
the broad bolts, which is really nice.
But basically, if my average is 270 GP
for each amethyst bolt tip, as you guys
can see here, we take 270 * 101.
Obviously, that's going to be 27.3 mil.
Now, if we go ahead and add that on to
whatever the broadbolts here are worth,
which is 6 mil, uh we're going to go up
to 33.3 mil. Now, that's the total
amount that it cost us. But if we go and
buy an amethyst bolt tip or an amethyst
broad bolt, I guess, uh you can actually
see how much you're going to be able to
make. Now, these things have gone up a
little bit recently. They did have a big
dip about a week ago, but they are back
up. up. And as you guys can see here, I
can't even buy one for 441GP.
Uh, which is absolutely insane. But I
guess we could go ahead and make one or
I have one right here. We can insta sell
it and see maybe what it would go for on
the market. So yeah, 400GP. Uh, that's
that's incredible. I never expected to
get this margin and I was really happy
when I hopped on today and looked. So,
basically, as you guys can see, if I
paid 270 for each of these and then 60
about for each of these, uh, that comes
in about 330 per B per per bolt. And if
we're making 70 uh GP profit per one,
we're about to make 7 mil uh just by
putting these bolt tips together. And I
know a lot of people will say that like
my money-making methods are dead right
after, but for the most part, they're
not. And I'm going to go and get a ton
of XP because these I guess if we look
real quick, how much do I get off of
making 10? 106 XP. So, this is actually
going to be over a mill fletching. So,
this is going to take me a while. Um,
I'll be back here in a second. This is
just going to We're going to see where
we're at. Right now, I guess for uh
scale, I'm starting at 78 fletching. So,
we'll see where we get. All right. So,
to put this in perspective for you guys,
as you guys can see, I just went under
100,000. But if I go ahead and make one
set, I'm making 10 arrows. And if I'm
profiting 70 GP off of each arrow, I'm
making 700 GP per 10 or per set. Now, if
we consider that every time I press make
10, it takes about 10 seconds and I'll
make 100 arrows, which means, you know,
I'm making 7,000 coins in 10 seconds.
Now, in a whole hour, that's about 2.5
mil an hour, which is one of the I mean,
easily the best money-making method I
can do right now. Um, but it's just
ridiculous. I mean, honestly, it's
pretty insane. And I'm just really happy
that I got these at the right time and
that I can show them to you guys and you
guys can see that this stuff actually
does work. So, I'm going to be back here
after 100,000 arrows. And we'll see what
we got going. I guess one thing that we
don't even see out of this method is the
fact that you actually get XP from this.
I mean, I'm getting a,000 XP every 10
seconds. So, that's ridiculous. But, oh,
there we go. 79 fletching. Nice and
easy. We'll probably get up to like 84
or something off this. Oh my god. Here
we are. This is uh this this took a
while. Uh realistically, you can make
about 30k darts or I guess bolts per
hour. So, this should take about 3 hours
and 20 minutes. Took me a little longer
because I like to AFK a little more.
But, as you guys can see, I got all the
way up to 83 fletching. Actually, I
couldn't get 84, but I was pretty happy
with 83. You get a good amount of XP per
hour. If it takes you about 3 hours and
20 minutes, you could say, um, you're
getting 1.1 to 1.2 mil XP. So, that's
about 300k XP per hour. So, it was
really good method. I'm really happy
with it. Um, I know I won't be making as
much money now because they kind of
reached a relative peak at the time of
me recording yesterday and I'm a little
bit depressed that now they have to go
down. But over the last day, they've
lingered around 360 and I think I'm
going to try to sell them for that 339.
As you guys can see, I've bought a few
throughout the day. That was the last
one I bought and then they've gone
slowly down. But I think I get 360 out
of them, which would be really nice. But
the problem with that is by me even
making this video, I don't think I'm
going to be able to get rid of 101,000
of them by the time this video comes
out. So, this may ultimately hurt me. I
know a lot of people think I make videos
just to like screw over people and try
to steal their money, but I'm uploading
this and losing money. So, hopefully you
guys can appreciate that. I was just
trying to get out a good method for you
guys. But, it does sell out for 360. I
think I should make about 30 GP per one
coming in about 3 mil made in 3 hours 20
minutes. on top of that got 1.1 to 1.2
mil XP. So hopefully you guys enjoyed
the video. If you guys did, make sure to
leave a like. Finally back at college,
so we should be able to pump out some
videos for you guys. If you guys are
enjoying the content, make sure to tell
me down below. Subscribe to the channel.
Also, leave a like. Uh we got the clan
chat if you ever want to come and hang
out. We also have a Discord in the
description. I don't think I've
mentioned that a lot, so feel free to
hit that up. Get a lot of new people
over there. That'd be pretty nice.